it was the biggest political gathering
of any kind ever held in this country
and there was a reason for that
all these world leaders came to glasgow
because their politicians are telling
them
that they need to act and
we've heard about the peril that we fail
uh that we face if we fail uh we've
heard from the individuals who are
already living with the effects and
yesterday evening we finally came to the
kind of game-changing agreement that the
world needed to see
almost 200 countries have put their name
to the glasgow climate pact marking a
decisive shift in the world's approach
to tackling climate emissions setting a
clear road map to limiting the rise in
global temperatures to 1.5 degrees
and marking the beginning of the end for
coal power
because for the first time ever a u.n
climate change conference has delivered
a mandate to cut the use of coal power
for of coal power generation
and it's backed up by real action from
individual countries for example we've
arranged a multi-billion pound
partnership to help south africa ditch
coal and create new green jobs instead
on top of that we've broken a deal with
the g20 to end international finance for
coal by the end of next month
we've persuaded most of western europe
and north america to mirror the
commitment i made last december by
pulling the plug on financial support
for all overseas fossil fuel projects by
this time
next year
and when you add all that together it is
beyond question that glasgow has sounded
the death knell for coal power
it's a fantastic achievement and it's
just one of many to emerge from cop26
90 of the world's economy is now
following our lead here in the uk by
committing to net zero ending their
contribution to climate change
altogether
don't forget that when aloc took the
reigns of cop
it wasn't even a third who were
committed to net zero
the developed world is finally going to
hit the 100 billion
climate finance target or
of if only
a bit later than we would have liked
and over 130 countries have signed up to
halt and reverse deforestation by 2030
and between them those countries are
home to more than 90 percent of the
world's forests
we've got trillions of pounds of private
sector assets lined up with climate
goals and we've even managed to do
something that has eluded the world for
six years
by finalizing the paris rulebook
allowing us to move from interminable
debates about how to measure emissions
and instead get on with cutting them
of course my delight at this progress is
tinged with disappointment
those
for whom climate change is already a
matter of life and death
who can only stand by as their islands
are submerged their farmland turned to
desert their homes battered by storms
they demanded a high level of ambition
for this summit
and while many of us were willing to go
there
that wasn't true
of everybody and sadly that's the nature
of diplomacy
we can lobby we can control
we can encourage but we cannot force
sovereign nations
to do what they do not wish to do it's
ultimately their decision to make and
they must stand by it
but for all that
we can be immensely proud
of what has been achieved by alex sharma
and his team
i want to take this opportunity to thank
him for his many months of tireless
diplomacy and thank everyone involved in
making cop 26 a success from the
bubble-hatted volunteers to peter hill
and his team in the crop unit there he
is
uh i know it's tempting to be cynical
and to dismiss these types of summits as
as talking shops but we came to cop with
a call for real action on coal cars cash
and trees and real action is exactly
what we've got
and
just look at what it all means for our
planet
before paris
the world was on course
for a devastating four degrees warming
by the end of this century
after paris remember
we were heading
for three degrees
at glasgow
we've turned that dial down
to around two degrees increase and of
course that's still far too high
but for all our disagreements
the world is undeniably heading in the
right direction
even the most pessimistic commentator
will tell you that 1.5 degrees that goal
of restricting the growth in
temperatures to 1.5 degrees is still
alive
now the work
continues to make that ambition a
reality
alok is going to keep pushing along with
everybody else in the uk government to
strengthen the promises made in glasgow
and to make sure that they are delivered
and not diluted
the uk government is going to get on
with our own extraordinary record of
decarbonization
get on with delivering our green
industrial revolution
and exporting that revolution worldwide
there's still a long journey ahead of us
and
very little time
to complete it
but cop 26 has shown that we can do this
we can end our reliance on coal and
fossil fuels
we can put the brakes on runaway climate
change
and we can preserve
our unique planet for generations to
come
i want to finish by thanking once again
the people of glasgow uh for putting on
a spectacular summit and of course for i
want to thank police scotland uh as well
for everything that they did